to be with a man that is has
a previous children from a previous
relationship i'm not going to say oh he
needs to be he used to have eight
figures he needs to be single he can't
have i'm not doing that i know that okay
i've got a child my bargaining power is
less than a woman that doesn't have but
the thing is it would be it would be a
good deal for you because when a guy has
kids it's a sign of pre-selection that
he can take care of them so that's
that's the thing that like i see in
churches is they they tell men to accept
bad deals because it would be a good
deal for you it'd be a bad deal for him
what if he has kids
yeah even so
but he can take care of those kids i'm
taking care of mine right right but like
men don't care about your money like our
bargaining power is different it's
purity and youth where you get
protection and provisioning so you get
you get the benefits and he doesn't but
if you have the trump card of um being
cooperative being submissive that can
work
i'm saying it's not a good character
you're you're correct and it can but
what i'm saying is one there aren't
enough men in the church to even for
everyone to get married and the other
issue is that you're again you're
selling a used car for new prices when
if you you know when really you're on
sale
and you should be and you might have bet
like and i would think people in the
church like a lot of like the single
mothers i see in the church would have
better outcomes if they just put
themselves on sale because they also say
to be submissive
yeah and and being submissive isn't oh
you have to wait to marry me to have sex
but like because that's on your rules
but the men what's that
yes charlie stop it the men in this
channel
the men in the church are still are also
the ones that are actually on it like
in their favor they're not having
i've been courted by a man in church and
he didn't attempt to have sex with me
because he understood that and he was
single he didn't have a child you're
more likely to meet a man in church
but he wasn't he was willing to do the
journey with me because he took his face
seriously why didn't you marry him
because he wasn't the right one for me
no because you weren't attracted to him
because he's a simple no no
because because that's that's simp
behavior that's it like honestly because
if you if you had a son that was
childless you wouldn't want him to date
a single mother that's a born-again
virgin and you might not say born again
virgin but you may as well be yeah but
can i just say i actually know and a
couple who met in church i'm gonna give
you some hope here they both have
children and they have both they're they
married and they are having they're
expecting that but possibility of
possibility possibility or women women
like think in possibilities instead of
probabilities when the majority of the
women i see in the church are single so
you can say oh here's this fairy tale
that might happen to you but if you keep
selling a used car at new prices that
like the majority of women will end up
single and that's what you're seeing in
the churches walk into any church the
majority of the women are single
they think i've got jesus so i'm okay
and they think that but the problem is a
lot of women will be homeless even in
the uk you guys have a lot of bailout
programs but let's say let's say they
can't afford those anymore where will
you go do you have 2.5 million for
retirement you'll be on the streets and
so finding a relationship can be life or
death for a lot of women because he's
more vulnerable than women on the tree
so you can like you can say oh it's nice
and like like
here's this fairy tale that could happen
for you and i think it's because like
you're very sweet but the probability is
a lot lower yeah can i can i also say
that there's a lot of working parts to
um
being a single christian woman because
one of the reasons as well if especially
for those of you that are not spiritual
i dreamt that this man was not the man
for me i asked god is this the man and
eventually after a couple of weeks of
dating the guy god spoke to me jim said
he's not the guy yeah so at the end of
the day for me whoever i marry now
there's no divorce we are dying together
so i want to do it the right way okay at
the same time a lot of women do i agree
they do use jesus as a crutch without
doing the inner self work it's you you
will stay single if you do not do the
you know i just think to a guy this
sounds like nonsense but like this sound
this sounds like because it's because
because it sounds like nonsense to me
but and i'm not spiritual there's
there's things that you if you're not
using your spiritual eyes to see certain
things
no no no don't don't do that don't do
that i spent i spent 12 years in
catholic school i grew up in a catholic
face i actually wanted to be a virgin
till i was married and i and i waited a
long time and and like didn't get
pregnant didn't do any of that so you
can't say oh it's like a spiritual thing
you don't feel rich
but i'm saying i'm saying you can say it
like inner work like whatever but like
i'm talking about results but i'm
talking about a spirit-led life not
going to church church going to church
you're not being marked on your
attendance
your god weighs your heart so you could
be going to church there's people that
never miss a sunday but their heart is
black
and i i understand i understand that
like but what i'm saying is like the
world doesn't owe you understanding
that's fine
and that's fine but i'm saying like if
if you don't have 2.5 million to retire
there's a chance you could be homeless
if you don't figure out how to get along
with a dude and it's going to be hard to
do that if you're selling a used car for
new prices fair enough but i'm also in
business myself i'm i provide for myself
i'm not um quick question please what
was the reason for
single ladies being in church what was
it is there does anyone know the main
reason i mean i i i think that like the
church has driven out men because one
they tell them to accept bad deals too
they thought they'd go to church and
find a wife and they found the girls are
freakier in the church than out of the
church
and three like feminism has infiltrated
a lot of and and feminine and guys guys
one at a time and feminism has
infiltrated a lot of the churches and so
it's like they don't really stand for
anything anymore i see i see that i mean
i don't know if this drives out men in
particular but i see i see gay flags
outside of churches not my church
so what
on the other side what do you think are
the reasons why we don't have men in
church
i think i think i think the church has
driven out men because feminism has
infiltrated the church agreed and so i
think they've taken power away from men
in the church and they've given it to
the women yes
call that the jezebel spirit the the
church has basically abandoned all of
the narratives that attracted men to it
in the first place
they don't emphasize the need to take
responsibility into you know the bear
your cross narrative that they used to
and
i i was raised atheist um i would now
describe myself as religiously confused
but i i recently attended church a few
months ago thinking you know this is
something i'm interested in i've been
developing a sort of spiritual practice
and i went there looking for that
narrative you know in in in the style of
jordan peterson who who picks apart the
biblical stories and explains what they
mean the significance they have to you
as a person and how you can improve
yourself as a person using the biblical
stories and i went there
and i found it really wishy-washy and
uninteresting
and slightly woke as well um you know
like in the middle of the sermon the
reverend started going on some tangent
about asylum seekers and refugees and
need to welcome them all in and things
like that and
although
i think that's a separate conversation
to the church and that's not what the
the whole point of the religious
endeavor is that it's supposed to be
about introspection and making yourself
a better person not about this social
justice thing that they seem to have
picked up and so i think that's why a
lot of men are leaving the church or
even even like roe versus wade in the us
that should be a win for churches
it is like that yeah it should be but
but it's not like even even the church i
was involved in in the us they can't
come forward and say that's a win
exactly so secularism has infiltrated
the church yeah there's not that what i
agree i think um
jesus
that guy on the cross like this yeah
kinky you know he's been feminized
they've feminized god and at the end of
the day i agree with what you said if
you actually look at the accounts of the
bible men were men
women women were led by men there was a
men had authority and i think you are
absolutely right feminism has
infiltrated the church and that male
authority is not encouraged or
celebrated even in society as a whole
masculinity is frowned upon you're
called toxic quickly nowadays a man
can't even say oh hey babes you look
good can i get your number because even
on the train now like don't get me wrong
some things are necessary like touching
without consent is inappropriate but
generally a man is not encouraged to be
an alpha male or i know that was thrown
around but i mean someone that is
aggressive not in a negative way but you
know actively masculine that is frowned
upon yeah well and i also think
i think they encourage simp behavior
they tell you to wait for a born-again
virgin and they i don't know why they
would tell girls to wait but the man
also is told to wait as well yeah but
you know it's different it's like a bad
deal for him because he still has to
protect and provide but he doesn't get
purity or youth she's but he's so he
looks around so yeah so before she got
to the church it's like oh it's like
slinging willy as well yeah but it's not
but men and women but here's okay okay
i'll give you an example but men and
women aren't the same so i went to
carnival and i interviewed men yeah i
said what would you rather pick would
you rather have a girl that had 50 000
worth of credit card debt you have to
pay off or 50 bodies and i asked the
same question to men and to women and
the women said you know i can deal with
the bodies i'm not taking the debt and
the guy said i will pay off 50 000 in
debt before i before i take a girl with
50 bodies
and and so it's like men and women don't
value purity at the same rate
men that that's like one of the most
important things to them they don't want
to be with a girl that has done
embarrassing [ __ ] in the past that's
embarrassing to them where women don't
we don't really care it's kind of a
flesh
the body count over the debt as many of
you know i was just banned on tic tac
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible